otherwise we'd all be feeling more
connected than ever actually because of
social media because of algorithms
because of these things and so like if
you really want to stay nash necessary
in an age of automation like you either
have to be creative or you have to
connect people how do you do that
but huh I believe that each and every
one of us has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and I want to help give you the tools to
make that happen
I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense today on the show I'm speaking
with Caitlin Turner who if anyone does
yoga or follows just really beautiful
pictures on Instagram she goes by gipset
goddess on Instagram and I followed her
for a really long time she is a
beautiful girl she has wonderful things
to say in her captions and I thought man
I really want to talk to this talk to
this girl she seems interesting and
truth be told I didn't really know
exactly what to expect because do you
know what to expect when you only know
somebody on Instagram but it was better
than I could have ever expected we had a
lot of things in common we talked about
artificial intelligence we talked about
confidence we talked about growing and
discomfort she was she took me by
surprise and I'm really glad that we
were able to have that conversation and
able to have this platform for both of
us but for her to be able to say more
instead of just a short little caption
we got to expand on things and I had a
lot of fun and I hope you do too I think
was story that I read that resonates
with me is like a great example of how
we can manifest in our life by asking
for something was when I read that you
were being asked why you were posting
spent so much time posting on social
media and you were like who knows maybe
one day I'll get a TV show out of it and
you did yes that I usually happened with
a lot of things like so many too
four versions of that I remember when I
was first starting to do my Instagram it
was just yoga photos and I went home for
Christmas and I asked my dad to help me
take yoga photos and at the time I
couldn't even really do a handstand or
anything so it was really hard to take
photos of me because I could hold a
handstand for one second and then I'd
fall it you got a photo of course now we
know you just take a video and you just
go to that one frame where you're
standing up and then it screenshot it
and it looks like you've been holding
baby that would have done way more
clever and I wasn't doing that my dad
was like Kaitlin I don't understand why
are we doing this and I said well dad
you know maybe one day I'm gonna have
like 10,000 followers and I'm gonna get
to go visit my favorite designer in her
studio and I'm gonna get lots of press
and you just kind of shook his head and
was like yeah sure Kaitlin sure you are
but then I got to go visit that designer
in her showroom and who was it it was
Mara Hoffman only as these amazing
prints and then I got written up in the
New York Times Style section which is my
dad's favorite newspaper in that moment
I had kind of made it and he still tells
the story now even though it happened
back in like 2014 like she told me she
was gonna get all this press and meet
this designer and she did I'm a TV show
- all free yoga I mean I I totally agree
with that I think about the businesses I
have and how they were all just ideas
they were tall just thoughts in my head
and then they came to life and now
they're something and you have to ask
for the things that you want and imagine
them so where did that sort of a
dreaming imagined imaginative quality
come from I think I've always had it
I've just always had a big imagination
ever since I was a kid and I used to get
really stressed out I can remember even
being like five years old and I would
get so stressed out at school when they
would ask me what I wanted to be when I
grew up because I never really had a
clear answer because what I wanted to be
I knew when I grew up is somebody that
created something I didn't know what yet
but enough so that I could work with my
family and all of my friends so that we
could you know I'll have money and go
travel together and play but there
wasn't really a career that had that
name and it turns out
that I grew up and created that career
that's so cool I just think it's it's
not as complicated and as hard or
impossible as people try and make it and
you just have to really know what the
heck it is that you want directionally
or emotionally sometimes I asked for
that like I'm like I just want to have
an adventurous life that's joyful and
fun and I want to travel and then all of
a sudden like those were my goals not
very long ago and this year like
traveling was a big one especially I
knew I wanted to travel after I was done
racing and I have probably taken I mean
I took eight trips in two months at the
beginning of the year wow that's a
little yeah everything from Austria to
New Zealand to Mexico and all over the
place and it's like you know you just
have to set an intention for for what
you want but Travel something I love and
you've done a ton of travel I have it's
funny because I I actually used to be
really afraid to travel I I think I I
just hadn't seen that much of the world
and I was really afraid to step out of
my comfort zone or like go somewhere
where English wasn't the main language
and I got really there programming
though I think that in this country and
it's just this is my opinion but I think
in this country we try and scare you
we not I someone tries to scare us away
from leaving
like Mexico scary and don't go to Africa
and don't go here and it's dangerous I
don't know about you but everywhere else
I go I feel actually more safe than here
and a lot of ways yes because I feel
like you're right there are so many fear
tactics here and it's not even hard to
scare people like especially now in this
current climate I think we're going in
such a different nationalistic direction
than we have in the past and I heard the
crazy statistic the other day that only
11 percent of Americans have passports
yeah I heard that so recently it thought
I think I think I heard it was even less
than that but that's so sad right and
this is interesting because you hear so
many people like complain about our
country for example and it's a well have
you ever been to any others so I did a I
did an Instagram post it was like NAT is
like world world day or something like
that
and
like I was just like some you know kind
of prettier picture like landscape ish
and my caption was about traveling and
how I've been to 31 countries which
turns out it's only 12 percent of the
world and I want to keep traveling more
and everywhere I go it's so beautiful
and you know you just have to kind of
set the date and go and if you you know
means are difficult than plan ahead and
people are like oh wouldn't it be great
if you know you know how people are
right they just absolutely Debbie down
which like I couldn't you know some
people have to work and that's not
possible I'm like yeah it must be nice
yeah must be nice you're like well you
you know if you don't think you can go
you never will right because as we
talked about at the beginning you
manifested all this stuff to happen in
your life because you you asked for it
in a way you said it you put it out
there and these people all they're
putting out there is I can't do that
well then you're gonna suck and you're
just gonna not do that that's so true I
broke through that with travel but I've
definitely been struggling even recently
with that feeling of I can't because I
came from a family of entrepreneurs and
I've almost started like ten different
companies and every time right before it
was about to launch I got so afraid of
failure that I kind of ended up
sabotaging and killing the whole thing
and now I'm doing it again but this
one's actually gonna start but it was
totally that mentality of I can't I had
this story that I can't do things on my
own and that I can't figure things out
on my own so then when I would try to do
things on my own that's not even true
I'm a really intelligent person I can
figure out really complex problems so
it's a ridiculous story to have about
myself
what do you think that came from uh I
think I it came from my parents probably
a little bit they weren't really like
helicopter parents but I think they
always just really helped me with
everything almost to a fault
like I never made my own doctors of
Mable knew on any of these things where
you sort of slowly but surely learned
how to be an adult I kind of just
confidence a lot of those lessons
yep and so I feel like I'm finally
starting to break through and figure out
like I can figure things out on my own
and I can do that but what I experienced
in the past is that when you have that
story about yourself whether it's true
in actuality or not it's almost like our
minds don't want to be wrong
so when you have a story like that or
when I had a story like that my behavior
would start to reflect that story even
if it was true just so the story
wouldn't be wrong but of course not this
way I want of my life I mean of course
I've done that too in my life and I'm
like that's that's kind of how I
described it as um I said when I when
you have an idea like you will validate
the [ __ ] out of that idea to make sure
that you're right oh yeah you will look
like Inspector Gadget for every possible
reason and way that you what you're
thinking that's not a good thing is you
know it's the victim mentality you know
I'm gonna find evidence to why this in
this bad thought is totally real and I'm
totally not crazy mm-hmm but you're just
being more crazy yeah that's absolutely
crazy it's a date that's that's a that's
a very insightful thing to learn that's
not an easy thing to learn that you
recognize that on the inside you are
continuing the lie perpetuating the lie
in the story there's a there's a in the
mind you apparently as I'm not a
scientist but it really can't tell the
difference between truth and a lie so if
you visualize something enough and
believe it that in your subconscious
that is a reality mm-hmm just like
something that really happened to you is
on a slight side note of that you can
have an experience and over time when
you repeat this story to yourself over
and over and over again you can twist it
just a little more and a little more to
create a story in the end that you
repeat to yourself that is actually
barely even real anymore I've heard that
that most of the stories we have about
ourselves in our heads aren't even true
because they aren't even in the original
story and because I think you do those
little tweaks every single time you have
the memory until the original story and
the one that you carry around don't even
look the same next to each other right
this takes a lot of patience and
self-reflection to even step back enough
to recognize that instead of just like
going through you know being you know
the human race and you're just racing
towards the next thing to slowed down
enough
what other like
about those businesses that talking
about the businesses that failed well I
mean I can't even say that they failed
because they never even launched so I
mean I I feel like I failed more than
they did because the ideas were good
well they're in a holding pattern then
yeah that's in a holding pattern an
entire ebook I'm having splits it has
video material with it it's quite a
collection of things I worked really
hard on it
and then I just got so scared that
nobody would buy it and it would make me
look stupid but everyone would see that
I released this thing that completely
flopped that I ended up not releasing it
just that was that was where it stopped
as you just said and I'm not ready well
I mean it was a way longer conversation
and far more drawn out but that was
really the message behind it all and I
was gonna start a hat company like
making baseball caps and sort of like
vintage style trucker hats and I did a
ton of work on that one and then the
same thing I was like well nobody's
gonna buy this and I'm gonna look
ridiculous and it's kind of the same
story that keeps coming up like and it
usually comes up not even at a time when
I'm really thinking about the sales of
something that's kind of how it
manifests but I think when it really
comes up is back to that old story of I
can't figure it out like I'd get to a
step in the process that maybe involved
paperwork or some sort of accounting and
business or math that I didn't
understand well and yeah rather than
sort of looking in the mirror about that
I would tell a different story that I
was familiar with that was nobody's
gonna buy this and I'm gonna look
ridiculous it's gonna flop and I'd kind
of let that take it away rather than
recognizing that I had just simply
encountered an obstacle that I didn't
feel I could overcome do you have a hard
time asking for help
less so now which is probably why this
company is actually gonna launch but I
guess and things like that I do it's
weird I don't have a hard time asking
for favors mm-hmm
but I think I have a hard time asking
for help because in doing that there's
an admission of I don't know everything
and I think that's sometimes a hard one
for me to make sure well its
vulnerability it's a vulnerability to
say I don't know I need help but you
know brené Brown is a really insightful
you know woman who speaks on this so
much and you know when you ask someone
for help you put your there they they
learn to trust you and there's a
connection there because if somebody if
if you if I said to you Caitlyn I really
need your help with this
you'd be like gotcha what do you need
because it's a trust thing if you ask
somebody for something you respect them
and the the the you know the bond can
grow then so it's a totally hard thing
to do because you want to you know
everybody wants to be proud and do
everything themselves and control your
exterior appearance and how you land
with people yeah well I mean gosh you
know speaking of exterior experia
pearance that's you know being a social
influencer I mean that's like the name
of the game and I was super proud and
glad to see influencers be vulnerable
especially after time and so at the
beginning of the year when you had
talked about how you know you just don't
really feel authentic and you were gonna
show more instead of being gipset got us
on social media you're like you're gonna
see more Caitlyn yeah I was like [ __ ]
yeah
because like we want to see that as
consumers and I would consider myself
one of those because I follow you so I
want to know going back in time more
like what it like I think it's a very
intriguing and interesting role because
I think people you know we idolize
influencers in a way so how what what
was at the beginning what was it like
like when you run it really started when
you got your 10,000 followers well it
was at that time really amazing and
unexpectedly so because I had never been
into social media like I was the last
person I think to join Facebook I
probably didn't even join Facebook until
maybe 2011 or two
2012 and it was already at that time so
much a part of social interaction and
social condition like you remember at
that time going to parties and everybody
would be like what's your Facebook so we
can come back time like go to college so
I didn't get any of that either yeah I
well I even went to college and just
skipped the whole Facebook thing like
through that I was above it and I was
not gonna do it I think the social media
thing is weird and I'd even say to
people like here you can take my number
I don't do that Facebook thing I was
very against it and then I was teaching
yoga and I ended up dating somebody new
and it was kind of funny because he had
a lot of money he was really wealthy and
so I think that he and his world was
sort of like the Sun that everybody else
would sort of revolve around and rotate
around and so I think in an effect to
fit into his world I had to be on his
schedule and he was like so I like to
travel really often so I want to take
one to two international trips a month
this is when I got over my fear of
travel actually yeah yeah out of pretty
incredible so he was like I want to take
one to two international trips a month
but the thing is wow you still really
need to have something going on like I
don't want to just give you a credit
card and have you going to Ma the mall
and the spa and I was like well that's
great because I don't watch your credit
card to go to the mall or the spa and
that certainly can't be the sum total of
my life but also I don't think a job
necessarily exists where I'm gonna be
available and free to do all of this
travel with you and so he actually
pushed me out of my comfort zone he was
a really strong entrepreneur is a really
strong entrepreneur and he said well
there's this Instagram thing that seems
to be really up-and-coming and I see
girls on there doing yoga and he's like
and you teach yoga you're great at yoga
you're pretty we traveled to cool
destinations why don't you be like a
professional Instagrammer and this is
still like I'm new to Facebook let alone
write Instagram so I was like here just
build an Instagram account I don't even
use Instagram and we kind of got
together and
analyzed what everybody was doing there
and what was working and then we really
built it sort of from the start as a
business and granted I was authentically
sharing but the authentic me is somebody
who's not really on social media very
much so it's been kind of an interesting
run what part is harder to share is that
the the like the written part is that
the part Tish that's hard to share that
feels more often less authentic to you
or is it more about just the frequency
of people seeing you and knowing what
you're doing do you I mean is it the
physical part does the physical part
feel like you lack authenticity with
like yeah I don't just walk around in
swimsuit all day good cuz you're hot but
I like it I mean I think it's a mix of
all of those in terms of the lack of
authenticity and it manifests in
different ways at different times like
on the one hand I was a creative writing
major in college so writing is my thing
I love writing captions and I think I'm
pretty good at being vulnerable I hate
to say it but being vulnerable in a
calculated way where it's sort of driven
and designed to be relatable to people
and to tug people's heartstrings and so
there's almost a little bit of a lack of
vulnerability in that as much as I'm
being vulnerable there's still like kind
of a calculated nature to it but the
ones that feel inauthentic to me are
kind of more of the days where I don't
feel like writing anything I don't
really like have anything that I feel is
important to say or that I want to share
but let's say I have a sponsored post
that I need to get up that day so I'll
put up the post and then I'll just kind
of put a throwaway caption into it and
that doesn't feel authentic because to
me words are very important and
especially the way that we communicate
with the outside world yeah it's so much
of like who we are and how we're seen
and so I really like to be kind of
calculated about that too and what I
share and I don't like to share
throwaway stuff or even like what brings
the reflection of you and you I'm not a
throwaway but I have to do this I'm not
feeling it today yep so you're like oh
now you put that out there that you're
not interesting or not you know not
insightful or not inspirational and
you're like that's not me I
am but damn it today I'm not feeling it
today I just don't want to the frequency
is hard it is you know cuz I mean I've
met with a group at one point in time a
management group and they're like well
it needs to be this many posts and you
should do the video video and do this
and I'm like that's not me well it's
obviously your [ __ ] like you like so
tell me how I'm seriously gonna make
money off of that two extra a week or
one a day and one bit like go to hell
yeah well and I just it's social media
is hard as a career of being an
influencer because unless you're the
type of person that really thrives on
creating content and really thrives on
connecting with large numbers of people
which I'm sort of shy I don't thrive
necessarily on connecting with large
numbers of people and I feel like the
direction that social media is going is
it's wanting like more and more and more
of our time not just as users which of
course it does because that's like where
ad money comes from but also as the
creator is like now a photo and a video
shared you know even every day isn't
enough anymore because now you need to
be storying throughout the day and you
need to be making likes produced videos
for IG TV and all of these things so
much it's hard to like keep growing in
that way I feel like sometimes my stuff
has plateaued because I'm only willing
to give so much of my life up to this
thing yeah and I think in order to
really really succeed you need to give
up so much more of your life well swing
do you end up living your life through
the lens and like you're you know when I
follow some people who talk to their
phone a lot and I'm like I just couldn't
do it like it's as if they have a
relationship with their phone they do
like and I just can't do it like I mean
I hold the phone up and I'm like hi oh
god that was bad that was Domino say
magistrate I feel so dumb and it sparked
a bit of vulnerability but also like
it's a weird concept I've you ever seen
there any talk to your phone like this
so your receiver yes Joaquin Phoenix yep
where he sorts of data's operating
system oh my god I feel like we're not
away from that being a reality I agree
with you and it's scary because I see
that in some people that follow that are
willing and able to story all day long
and have their you know the posts are
almost just like you know
secondary but the stories are ongoing
okay so getting back to getting back to
the lineage of you know becoming an
influencer so you and your boyfriend you
do your you do your research you kind of
know what's going on so you start
traveling you go on and how many years
would you say you you did that before
you started to feel like this isn't me
or did it start right away uh it didn't
start right away because I was just
having fun with it in the beginning
I've always been it's weird I've always
been a pretty shy person in my real life
but when it comes to a performance
context like being on a stage and acting
or doing public speaking or any of that
kind of thing I can step up to the plate
really effectively and this was an
interesting thing because on social
media if anything I was basically like
playing myself and stepping up as myself
so at first it was this beautiful ground
where I could sort of practice being
myself like it was hard to do that if I
showed up at a party and didn't know
anybody for example like real me it
would rather probably like hide in the
bathroom than like get into the thick of
it and make some new friends
so Instagram was this beautiful practice
ground where I could be myself and just
see how it landed with people and feel
that affirmation when it was positively
received yeah and at that time it was
really fun because I was making a ton of
real friends even if they were online
friends they were still people that I
talked to very often and they were real
friends and it just helped me grow so
much as a person because it really
stepped into more like being Who I am
and not being afraid to show up as that
rather than trying to show up as you
know whichever version of me the
situation demands but honestly like with
so many things I think what it started
feeling inauthentic was when money came
into the picture because do you remember
your first sponsor do I wet it I
remember your first sponsor uh yes allô
yoga and there lobello
still wearing yellow oh yeah I've been
sponsored by them for five years which
has been really incredible but it's also
been somewhat of a blessing and a curse
because I realized after a couple years
of being sponsored for alo that a
substantial part of my joy before that
had come from picking out you know yeah
different reactivity about this and yeah
exactly and granted alo has a million
pieces so
I have a ton of room to be creative but
at the same time like by slightly
limiting my creativity that way it
definitely took some of the joy out of
it I mean I get it I lived in a world
where I would grab a bottle of water and
if it wasn't the sponsor of water like
everybody's ripping labels off like
everywhere I went people were taking
labels off of water bottles I'm like
does anybody really give a [ __ ] people
totally gutter
well the sponsor gives a [ __ ] right and
but it's like it's I just live in a
world where I could never like nothing
could be in the background of a picture
you couldn't talk about something you
couldn't be in a video with something
using it because you'd be even if you
weren't directly promoting it because it
was part of your life you'd be
indirectly promoting it and you just
live this life where you have to be
careful what's in every picture and
everything you say and everything you
have because you're like I don't want to
get in trouble for having the wrong
stuff when you know when you rely on
that as income yeah yeah that was and
that was their world that was that was
the world what I'm curious like I mean I
love like a load has done a great job of
you know getting all of you influencers
together and doing like it was a really
clever campaign yeah go and do the alo
retreat thing where you know they've got
aloe and flowers like the size of like a
small house and you know the unicorn
floaties and all the stuff and they take
care of you and meals and everything and
all you guys are posts about it because
of course it was done in beautiful
locations with beautiful people but
other than that I mean like what's your
obligation of them
well mostly I I mean of course I have a
certain number of posts and stories and
that kind of thing that I heard a per
week per month it's a monthly thing and
they're not too stringent there are
definitely doable expectations which I'm
really grateful for because there are
certainly other companies out there that
just have the craziest lists of things
that you need to complete where it
doesn't feel creative anymore so there's
that but I think the main part is that I
can't wear any clothing from any
competing activewear brand yeah which is
fine because Alice clothes are honestly
yeah they do
realistic I mean look like nobody I mean
you can be someone that makes you know
high-end anything you go on a red carpet
you're probably gonna wear that every
single time you know what I mean so it's
no matter what it is you don't wear one
brand your whole life so it does but and
the thing is is like people get that
right but they also somewhat own that
category with you so they absolutely did
is it like in your everyday life as well
as in your well if I go to a yoga class
or something you will never see me
wearing Lululemon actually I don't even
know Lululemon which is why that's a
perfect example faded away yeah yeah I
finally just you know I think in the
beginning I kind of like held on to some
other brands that I liked but then same
as you're saying here like even in your
regular life you're like oh well I can't
use this cuz I could get in trouble and
it's in a picture and you can see the
label and or even like I'm recognizable
enough within the yoga world that it's
like I wouldn't do this but if I were to
go to a yoga class wearing Lululemon was
so many people know that I'm sponsored
by a low like it can't easily get back
I'm like oh I saw chips that got us at a
yoga class and she was wearing Lululemon
that's crazy well it's cool though that
you got to collaborate and do a little
like collection with them yeah it's like
I'm going or was that I remember it had
like flea feathers on it and so yeah we
did that for I think about two or three
years yeah and well I really liked the
collection I thank you and that was
actually the reason I said yes I had had
a bunch of yoga clothing companies come
to me and say we only want you to wear
our clothing exclusively but I was never
that motivated to do it because like I
said it was such a joyful experience to
me to pick out my outfits but then the
CEO of ello emailed me one day in let's
see five years ago so 2014 and he was
like hey I'm in Arizona and I'd love to
take a meeting with you I'd like to talk
to you about exclusively wearing our
clothing and potentially doing your own
line which is what I really wanted yeah
the whole time but I knew that I didn't
know enough about how to do that so the
thing that I was really working hard at
that time to manifest was I wanted to do
a capsule collection for somebody
because that's what you did yeah cuz it
was this beautifully safe way to learn
all of these things yet work with the
professional design team see how they do
things but then at the same time not
have the risk
investing in the right financially so
it's like he said the mat and at that
time I didn't think aloe was cute at all
because they had just done a big rebrand
and before they were doing like skorts
and weird things that I would not wear
but I he said the magic words like
potentially do your own line and I took
the meeting and the rest is history and
I'm so glad I did they did really good
cool well I mean there's opportunity
opportunities come with responsibilities
but so that came along so like fast
forward so now you you finally get to
the point where you're like I've had
enough like how long did you like what
what was the breaking point
I think the breaking point was likely
just one too many sponsored posts
because I think in the beginning whether
I was being authentic and vulnerable or
not wasn't even a part of my thought
process because I was always being
authentic and vulnerable so it wasn't
even something that I had to think about
consciously but then as money became
more involved in with one off sponsored
posts like brands yeah trip to work with
brands oh yeah I really want to get
their exact message out there but they
want to do it sort of they want to give
it they want to give you the the the the
there's an official there's a better
word for it but the text they want they
give you the writing a brand message the
brand message the hashtags and there's
always too many of those and the ATS and
they want to the the message is always
super generic
well yeah and especially like sending
things in for approval like I'll write a
caption that although it's a sponsored
post I actually feel ok sharing it and
it feels like me and they'll send it
back and it's just got tons of jargon
and exact slogans put into it and I'm
like this isn't even me anymore and so
then it's this weird thing where I kind
of have to share something that I'm not
actually proud of anymore
and I think doing that enough times just
really started away on me
yeah and granted I'm not away from it
like I still do do sponsored posts and
that kind of thing sometimes but I try
to be way more discerning about who I
work with so that it really can feel you
know just like on brand but so that I
can actually feel like me and as you go
on and you earn the credibility and the
status which you have to you know be
move the needle you have leverage and so
then you can go to them and you can say
you need to let me rewrite these posts
and my words and things like that like
ask those things you can definitely ask
for a conversation a lot yeah like wow
am i right would they write I will
rewrite what they write but I'm not
going to post exactly what they want
because it's um again you're putting
something out there that's not you and
if the job is to be authentic it's not
being accomplished well I think it just
I got to this place where it didn't feel
like me anymore and it almost was easier
to just it's funny sometimes I talk
about gipset goddess and Kaitlyn in the
third person because it's almost like
there are two different people like I'll
be talking with my boyfriend and I'll
say like oh you know he'll points out of
an article of clothing for example and
I'll be like oh chips that goddess would
wear that but I don't really like it
because there became like this schism
between like who I am in real life and
who I was playing online and I think I
just started resting and on my laurels
and it was so much easier to play this
sort of yoga character who is like happy
all the time and just manifesting my
dreams no matter what life throws at me
which are like valuable things but like
I wasn't living it I was just talking
about social media exacerbates those
things yes we have the ability to filter
things out remember when we would take
pictures and it was with a disposable
camera a regular camera and you'd send
in the film and then you'd get it like
it just was what it was and you'd sit in
the car and look at the pictures because
you hadn't really seen them yet and now
I mean you'll take 20 pictures and
you'll be like oh and not that one hang
on let me do this one more time the
Lighting's better okay if I just do this
like your pre filtering the filter like
and it's you know the it's it's it's a
very fake world but it's not that we've
never done it it's just that social
media is an easy way to do it and I
think this happens in regular life too I
mean this this is really more of a
parallel of so many different situations
you can look at a family that looks like
they're really happy and you know maybe
you're best friends with them and you
know that their marriage is super on the
rocks
and you know their kid is getting in
trouble at school or whatever it is and
so you know there's there's so much
stuff that we hide about ourselves and
with social media it's this it's even
worse it's just really just well you get
some a magnified version of that because
with social media comes so many tools
that encourage us to do that like sure
you can do it in your real life you know
you can be the family who's having
marital marital marital problems but
shows you know a happy face to the rest
of the world but with social media
there's like facetune and filters and
all of these different things where that
little voice inside us that negative
voice that's like you should change this
usually this your waist should be
smaller your moves bigger I mean
whatever it is okay there's a tool in an
app for that what have you used I'll be
honest about what I'll yeah I've used
facetune in the past I kind of use it in
a funny way though I definitely use it
sometimes but it's because I'm not a
model and I don't have these skills to
know the exact right angles so like I
have a pretty great body and I love my
body and I love my face but every once
in a while in photos there is just a
funky angle that's like not even true to
who I am so you don't recognize it yeah
where I'm like oh my god does my like do
my hips look like that does my waist
look like that like where did those even
come from so I think I've mostly used it
to kind of like try to bring the photo
back to how I actually look um when it
gets funky but I mean I've definitely
done some shady things I've corrected
yoga poses with facetune before like I
said I kind of use it in weird ways like
I don't you know give myself an
hourglass figure but I might like
straightening me every now and then huh
yeah I would say that for me I I mean I
remember seeing this picture of someone
and I was like that girl ain't that tall
I know who she is and then I looked up
on Google if you could download an app
to make you taller you can yeah
there's literally an app for everything
to the perspective of the photo yes and
but I don't I I though the only stuff
I'll do is I will like brighten or if
some kind of a if something a lighter or
picking up highlights or shadows like
highlights shadow I don't have an extra
app for anything I just use what
Instagram has so so if it so if it maybe
smooths my face out a little let's say
or like look makes me look like I have
less wrinkles well you know maybe I will
use that but I don't do anything
additional like there's nothing outside
of what Instagram offers and even with
Instagram I really try and I try and
make sure that the filters not one
that's like I got never use the ones
where you look like a damn puppy dog or
whatever it is and some of them like the
beauty filters and stuff I don't use
those because I don't do stories really
so it's really just the options that are
in the Instagram picture options I
definitely use the story filters and you
cut things you can kind of tell yeah and
it's just like overly smooth yeah like
your eyes get a little bit bigger
you just take on a little bit more of a
cat-like look that's what I say over
Mike everybody starting to look like a
cat I went through a phase when I found
this app called touch retouch that is
really effective at taking things out of
photos you can take out people around
you or that kind of thing but I also in
that app learned how to use the clone
tool oh so like I went a little crazy
with that at one time like my hair is
you know I don't have a ton of hair on
my head it's kind of like thin hair and
it's something I've always been
self-conscious about so like all of a
sudden with that clone tool I hide like
my hair oh my god then I went through a
phase with using that and facetune maybe
about two years ago where all of a
sudden I was editing everything like I
didn't like how this bush looked over
here so I'd paint in an entire wall of
ivy and to the point where the photos
didn't at all look the same as where
they initially were and that was
definitely a low point for me that I
kind of had to like shake my head and
wake up now is it that crazy because
you're doing it to feel better about
yourself but in the end all you feel is
worse
oh absolutely there's this whole
psychological phenomenon about how
people are using Instagram and snapchat
filters especially the 'story filters
and so they get really used to seeing
their face ya know lines and
with bigger eyes and so then they take a
normal selfie and look at their face or
even look at their face without a
counter and they're like I look like
[ __ ] where did ya go my girl why are my
eyes this size a little piece like
actually that's how you look but you've
literally been viewing yourself through
a filter this whole time until you
forget what you actually look like in
real life and expect to see the filter
and that's not what's there so have you
grown from this sort of confession yeah
I think so a little bit I actually did a
public speaking thing it wasn't a TED
talk but it was similar format a few
years ago and I was supposed to prepare
this whole thing but it came to be I'm
always a bit last-minute with everything
and so it came to be like five days
before and I had nothing and I was like
oh my god her to do this talk for 20
minutes what am I even gonna do and so I
talked to that daunting good for you I
talked to the person who was hosting it
and we were going through different
topics that I thought I could talk about
but they were all kind of safe and one
time when I first met him we had had
this lunch where I it was a dark day and
I ended up breaking down crying with
somebody I had never met before about
how inauthentic my and they're like
who's crazy girl oh baby went away he's
like a self-work guys he's like yes this
is what you need to talk about and I was
like really you think I should just
throw my whole Instagram under the bus
for this talk huh and he was like yeah
that would be inspiring so I did I in
the end didn't have it written but I
walked up there with like a 25 photo
slideshow that I had created and there
was some really scary before and after I
was like I actually did throw my
Instagram under the bus and in this talk
I threw up on the screen all of these
different photos where I had seriously
photoshopped it whether it was the
background or my body or different
things like captions that had been lies
and I think ever since I had that moment
it's been so much easier to have these
conversations where I can own my own
inauthenticity because it's like by
naming it that it loses its power over
you that's a you just set it and there's
so many people that say that and have
written that but by calling the problem
out you don't give it power and you get
it's really true yeah it's it's a it's a
tough hurdle to cross but I have a
saying forgive things that are difficult
that the only way out is through so and
so if you don't go through that
sort of like confession or admission or
you know you're afraid of being
vulnerable so the exact thing you need
to do is be vulnerable and it takes away
the fear of it and the power of it to
control you well it's sort of like
addiction you know like in any type of
study of people handling addictions like
a any of these they always say that the
first step is recognizing that there's a
problem and I think that's right they
say it they're like my name is and I'm
an alcoholic
yeah that's a really powerful thing and
I think that that's across the board and
all of our problems like I think so many
people are addicted to sort of being
there in authentic selves and like
showing up a certain way and like until
you call out how you've been inauthentic
it's hard to ever be authentic without
recognizing that well where is this all
going right like where is all this going
because at some point in time we're not
gonna know what we look like everyone
looks like anymore I mean there's just
so many they're getting better I mean I
don't know about you but this whole like
make yourself older app that just came
out
I mean fix me out I it freaks me out
because I actually wonder what they're
doing I wonder I actually wonder if the
purpose of some of this stuff is to
develop AI so that it can you know learn
you better and learn people better and I
part of an just part of data basically
like it's an ear challenge data right
that everyone said about that that like
if we wanted to train an AI like what
would be the perfect way to do it like
an AI aging thing hey man so they asked
for ten years ago to now now they're
asking for now - what is it probably 30
years a down line or something 20 30
years of ages you I mean that AI is now
giving getting data and information and
what you look like for your entire like
the exact same thing and I think that's
very efficient and all of that it's
totally I absolutely agree I'm so happy
to have this conversation because so
often I talked to other people who are
influencers and they don't see it like I
didn't do the 10 year child I didn't
either because that [ __ ] totally freaked
me out that's right how many people I
know did
and I was like don't you think it's
weird like have have you just thought
this one through oh no that was a
popular post so we all just jumped on
the bandwagon and later even that kind
of thing where you know something freaks
you out inside and gives you a little
bit of a creepy feeling but like
everyone just jumps on the bandwagon cuz
it's the cool thing to do right now like
just seeing so many people jump on a
bandwagon like that when you ask me
really question it and not as much want
to be on it yeah and where does that
come from and who's controlling the apps
and the message and the promotion and
the like how how did that catch on
within like 24 hours like I feel like
within a day all of a sudden everyone
has this face app thing that shows what
you look like when you get old just like
the 10 year challenge thing was like
where did this stuff come from and all
of a sudden everybody's doing it it's
like you just have to look layers deeper
and you know do your research like
listen to listen to podcasts about
people that like there's something that
worked for Facebook that I listen to is
a very interesting information about
what they're collecting one of the
pieces of information from that was that
you know the when you sign into
something and it's asking for fun one
final last step of you to click on all
the boxes that have a light lamppost in
it or something and how is like notice
that's getting harder as the AIA needs
to learn better yeah so those are all
really trippy things that are going on
in the world we're all going along with
it because it's fun it's accessible it's
easy it's cool but it's not going it's
not necessarily innocent yeah you have
to question the intentions of it I think
about that in so many ways like
technology just like as you know normal
people who are not like high up in the
tech business like we don't even know
all of the things that's going on behind
the scenes with technology and I think
about you know virtual reality and these
kind of things and automation and I read
this really interesting article about
how the reason that so many of the
Silicon Valley companies are putting in
a ton of money into virtual reality is
due to the fallout that automation is
going to cause because so many people
with all of these traditional jobs that
just aren't going to exist anymore are
basically going to be a class of like
the jobless and
those people need to do something with
their time and so a lot of people are
trying to make a lot of Silicon Valley
companies are trying to make like a
really strong virtual reality play for
like the jobless of the future and I
think that you know training AI and
training all of these things and you
know making the virtual world look that
much more cohesive with the world in
which we have it like I wonder about all
of this so you've obviously listened
Elon Musk's stuff about the probability
of being in a virtual reality is yeah
it's so extremely high in a simulation
and that theory I read a book called
holographic universe and it's a very
fascinating read - well I mean even
scientists have said we can break down
literally everything into zeros and ones
which is just crazy and then when you
think about when you go out into your
world and how small the world seems and
like oh but I follow you and I know you
and oh you're from there and you just
kind of wonder if your own mind is
really creating your reality because
it's some kind of freakin virtual
realities thing I mean it's all very and
then there are things that just don't
make sense right when you read
holographic universe you're reading
these stories of these unbelievable
experiences people are having that are
beyond physical comprehension of what's
possible and you're like but how and so
it makes you really wonder what is the
fabric of our reality and you know the
speaking to somebody yesterday like at
the end of the day whether you know or
don't know if you do live in a virtual
reality or not it kind of doesn't matter
right it doesn't although we as humans
really want to know the answer to things
we just want to answers right like we're
an answer seeking society and we're not
even gonna do anything with them but we
want to know just one another so then
the point is is then moving away from
like what is real and what isn't real
because we don't know mm-hmm maybe some
small sector of the world knows I don't
know I don't know if I maybe the
Illuminati knows if that's real or or
all of that whole world but then what do
we do like what is what do you feel like
is the next step then with all this
stuff in mind
this is fake this is real whatever like
how do you want to walk forward in your
life and how do you want to how do you
want to be remembered I think the
biggest thing that we can do is live in
the present now because you're
absolutely right we don't know any of
those answers and so without knowing
those answers it's really hard to plan
accordingly so I think it's so much
easier to focus on the things that we
can control and the things that we do
you know rather than the things that we
don't and you know we can control
everyday in the present and like of the
things that we can control in the
present some of those lend well to
building the future that we want to
build so I think we all really just need
to tune into ourselves and make sure
that we're still connecting with other
people
I think connecting with other people is
so much of how we grow and in this world
that says we're more connected than ever
I think so many people out there feel
less connected and I think it's really
important that we need to keep on
staying connected because it's good for
our minds it's good for our bodies it's
good for our psyche but honestly it's
also good for like if automation is
something that you're worried about like
computers can't connect people otherwise
we'd all be feeling more connected than
ever actually because of social media
because of algorithms because of these
things and so like if you really want to
stay nash necessary in an age of
automation like you either have to be
creative or you have to connect people
how do you do that
uh-huh well my creativity manifests in a
lot of different forms I I mean of
course obviously through photos and
videos that I share on Instagram and
yoga sequences but also just through
creative thinking like it's so easy to
think about things the way that we're
taught or think about things the way
that we learned them in school and I
think it's so important to be creative
in the way that you think about things
and creative in the way that you view a
problem like maybe rather than trying to
solve it the traditional way when that's
really hard you get creative and find an
easier way to solve it like I'm really
inspired by trying to solve complex
problems and that's also I think a big
way that I connect with people to tie
the two together is I think that I've
sort of become inadvertently a
relationship coach to so many of my
and it's because I really like
problem-solving especially when they're
complicated so they come to me with
these really complex problems that
they're dealing with in the present yeah
and I want math problems you're talking
about emotional problems I'm talking
about like life people problems yeah
problems business problems I mean I
think so often we work harder when we
could be working smarter but it's
because we're all like in our own narrow
perspective and so I think I'm really
good at connecting people by being the
person that they can come to and ask
them questions to help them get out of
these like horse blinders that they're
wearing and I think just through I
creatively solve problems and share that
information with people and it all sort
of feeds into my creativity and helps me
connect with people and helps other
people connect with each other is that
something you've always done or
something you do more over now it's
something that I've been doing more of
now I mean I think I've always had good
advice but I didn't trust myself and say
it with the same sort of authority and
vigor as I'm able to now because I
believe in myself so much more and I
learned a lot recently about channeling
and different people who channel and
we're talking about Abraham Hicks we
were and I don't know who or what I'm
challenging but when it comes to a
complex problem and finding a unique
answer and a unique solve for it
sometimes these words just come into my
head I don't even know where they're
from and I'll like stop people make
conversation and be like you know what
this is so weird I don't even know why
I'm telling you this but I just feel
like I have to tell you this thing and
I'll tell them and they're like wow this
is the answer I've been looking for that
whole time I've been grappling with this
for weeks and you just solved it in a
second and I don't even know where it
came from I so conscious very
interesting because I've had I do that
but I do it on myself so yeah I will
certain situations usually has to do
with relationships a lot of times they
feel more sensitive but in certain
situations but basically if there's an
emotional context to it then I'll get
these like hits or words or phrases like
you know or like it'll be worth it yeah
or yes or you know they'll be like
phrases or words or something but you'll
you'll be you'll you'll get the answer
and it'll be repetitious like it's
always the same
and it's more for me I don't get it for
other people but it's that intuitive
quality that we all have that if you get
quiet enough to listen to it it's very
helpful but but I think it's I mean it's
it's I think it's where we're going as a
society as if we're going to grow in our
consciousness and evolve is that we have
to tap into this infinite source of
information that is available to us and
has no time and space as a dimension to
live in it is essentially in the ethers
of information that is always connected
and it's because it's powerful stuff
I've also done this something called
like I would call it like free writing
where I'll start writing and I'll and I
might just start writing but then I'll
also start to speak in a third person as
if I am like my soul or I am my
intuition and I'll start and I'll ask
the question and then I'll just start
writing the answer and I'll ask the
question and just start and it's not
with thought it's just with intuition I
call it like free writing I love that
it's like stream of consciousness yeah
yeah and it's like pretty cool stuff
well I feel like we need to hang out
because you can do it for yourself but
you don't do it for other people right I
can totally do it for myself you can
teach me your ways and I feel like it's
so much about intuition like I think
that that's why I'm able to do it for
people now is because I always had those
things pop up but I didn't really trust
them and I definitely didn't trust them
to say them I trust them enough to say
them out loud to people yeah and that is
you're like oh did I just make that up
yeah it's totally like where I study
would that come from why do I think I
know that yeah then I just slowly but
surely started like actually saying them
out loud and like when I had messages
for people I would share them and and
then when they validate them totally you
go I'll do it again I'm like oh gosh I
guess I should keep practicing this and
I feel like I'm just now starting to
kind of like hone in to that voice
minute you know talks for me but I think
it's just so much quieter like those
problems seems so much clearer to solve
than I oh man yes please hang out with
me and tell me about all the things that
I need to know
that are intuitive and in in the ethers
that you can help me with that's um
that's uh I think that that's I think
that's a really powerful thing and I
think that how did do you know how you
got to the point of being able to hear
it like is there a self-care program you
have that helped develop that or get you
quiet enough to hear it or where'd how
did how did that evolve well for other
people it just comes from listening I
think listening is something I've worked
really hard on because for the longest
time like I I'm sure you understand this
as well because you have so many great
stories I have a ton of great stories
and so especially with my social anxiety
sometimes it's easier to fall back on
just telling my own stories because I
know they go over well and that kind of
thing but then when I'm around people it
doesn't make them feel heard and
honestly I don't even hear them because
while they're talking I'm already trying
to think about the related story that I
have that I can share and so I realized
this about myself and I decided I really
wanted to break that pattern because I
wanted closer more connected
relationships in my life so I started
really focusing and listening and when I
listen to other people I really focus on
clearing my mind and hearing them and
making the space to respond to actually
what they're saying rather than respond
with my own version of it that I've
preconceived while they were talking and
and been distracted and don't listen to
the exact they're saying cuz you're
already like and when they're soon as
they're done I'm gonna start talking
yeah and I think that's like almost the
issue is I can do it for other people
because I get my mind really quiet with
the intention for sort of listening for
the words between the words and what
they're saying but I have such a hard
time doing that for myself like I don't
even meditate nearly as often as I
should or really very much at all it's
kind of a once in a blue moon thing and
it's probably guided meditations not
just God forbid sitting with myself and
I think that's why I can't really hear
the voice within me because I'm not
creating the quiet mind that I do for
other people where I can hear it yeah
that's uh so true that's interesting
well I feel like I've had the same
problem like this actually like doing a
podcast has taught me to listen because
I'm also the same like I have these
stories and as soon as
think pops into my head if I don't say
it I will forget and of course my ego
says this story's totally worth it they
need it they need this story but the
podcast has been a good exercise and
listening to people all the way through
and it's also you know the only way that
you can really have a both way
conversation as if you're listening and
if you're listening to me and I'm
listening to you and we're we could talk
for we could go on and on and on because
we're really integrated with each other
and playing off of each other instead of
just you know here's my stories here's
my stories here's my stories so it's
been a it's been an interesting
transition and also I'm so used to being
interviewed that it was like quite the
transition to go okay now I have to oh
god I have to prepare you know yeah so
but it's been really really cool so tell
me like as far as you know manifesting
what's next well I've had some
successful manifestation lately I feel
like I've manifested the love of my life
which is really exciting and now and
I've always kind of dreamed of creating
like I said when I was a kid I really
wanted to start a business where I could
work with the people that I love so that
like we have the same time on the same
time off in the same amount of money we
can all go play together and so I think
I always kind of had a secret dream of
starting a business with like my lover
my partner and now we're doing that so I
feel like I've kind of manifested both
of those things but the current
manifestation is I'm starting an incense
company well but I think to call it
simply incense cheapens it a little bit
because it's more Palo Santo and Wed
base less like traditional wood incense
yes that's all of it
sandalwood yes that's gonna happen any
any kind of wood that burns and has an
spiritual qualities to it we're probably
gonna ball fingers into yep so it's
gonna be largely based around Palo Santo
and go home
so I really would like to get that
released in less than six months and I'm
like I told you before I've let so many
times that I started businesses like let
those little obstacles that I've been Oh
trying to overcome stop me from doing it
but so I'm also just manifesting the
power within myself to just bruise
through all of those obstacles and keep
going no matter what and I have this
affirmation that I keep saying to myself
that's like it's not going to fail but
even if it does who cares
on to the next and before that was not
at all the narrative that I had in my
head so I'm just trying to manifest more
success in my life in the areas of
business and love and of course personal
growth but I feel like that's a bit
ahead of the relationships and love well
it's not easy it's painful I don't I
think that there's a misconception that
and you know I'm sure you've seen it as
I have like spiritual growth and you
know in reality versus in my mind and
it's like kittens and rainbows is what
you think it's gonna be like and what it
is like right and it's so much different
in reality so I always tell people that
just like the only way out is through
that you know there's no pain there's no
growth before pain you will have to go
through pain before you have growth
because you have to you have to let
things die you have to let things go
you have to transition you have to be
brave you have to stand in your truth
and all of those things are not easy
yeah but it sounds like you have faced
fears and you the basically the more
painful it is the better you're going to
come out the other side so and you know
just like when you get sick and you look
back and you think oh it wasn't that bad
in the middle of it you're gonna die
you're absolutely gonna die just like
when you're in the middle of whether
it's emotional or spiritual growth or
whatever it is personal growth mental
growth do you think you're gonna die
like there's no way I'm gonna get
through this and this is the worst and
as I've said it past times in my life I
just want to wake up in three months and
have it all be over with it is the
journey is the part it's the important
part is going through the mess and so
that's amazing that you've you know dug
in and gotten strong
and recognized your faults so that you
can face them and overcome them I think
that's a really I think that's a really
powerful thing and I'm I'm I'm inspired
by by that and I really appreciate you
coming and chatting with me and so
basically now you're coming over
afterwards and you're going to have a
channel for me and you're going to give
me hits and let me know what my life's
all about I would love to thank you so
much yeah thank you thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today I hope you enjoyed it if you like
what you heard today and you want to
hear more please click on the subscribe
button
you